لذلك اصيب الشاباني فلسطينيان برصاص قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قرب بلده برقيين غرب
مدينه جنين بالضفه الغربيه وقال الجيش
الاحتلال في بيانه الى دوريه من قوات
البضاليين نفذت هجوما استباقيا بحق احد
المسلحين الفلسطينيين بعد ان اطلق رصاص
عند حاجز دوتان العسكري واطلقت النار على
مركبته واصابته كما اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال
فجر اليوم قريه تياسير شرق محافظه طوباس
بحثا عن منفذي هجوم حاجز منفذي هجوم حاجز
الحمراء وتصدى شبان القريه للدوريات
العسكريه بالحجاره
واعتقلت قوه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي خلال
الليله الماضيه وفجر اليوم اربعه
فلسطينيين من مناطق متفرقه من الضفه
الغربيه المحتله
ثلاثه شبان خلال اقتحام قوه اسرائيليه
بلده الرام شمال شرق مدينه القدس المحتله
كما اعتقلت قوات الاحتلال شابه من قريه
بيت فجار جنوب بيت لحم اثناء عبوره من
حاجز الحمراء في منطقه الاغوار الشماليه
ونقلت قوات الاحتلال المعتقلين الى مراكز
التوقيف لتحقيق معهم في قضايا تتعلق
بمقاومه جنودها
من رام الله لنا مراسل الجزيره سمير ابو
شمانه والمشهد كما يبدو في ضوء توتر
الاخير وهذا الهدوء الذي يسوده الان وطبعا
وهدوء بالحذر
نعم بطبيعه الحال هناك حاله او واقع الان
هادئ جدا في عدد من الكثير من المناطق
الفلسطينيه وفي داخل القدس وداخل الخط
الاخضر ولكن هذا الهدوء هو مشروب بالحذر
الشديد خاصه بعد حاله التوتر الامني التي
سادت خلال الايام الاخيره الماضيه والتي
شهدت من خلالها عمليات وهجمات مسلحه من
قبل فلسطينيين ووقوع قتلى واصابات بين
الاسرائيليين الحكومه الاسرائيليه وعلى
لسان رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي او عذاب
بتعزيز وتعبئه القوات الاختيارات الخاصه
من حرس الحدود التابعه للشرطه الاسرائيليه
واضافه اربعه اربع سرايا من قواتها قوات
الاحتياط الى داخل المراكز وتعزيز هذه
القوات في مراكز المدن وايضا الاماكن
المزدحمه اضافه الى ست سرايا هي تعمل الان
في بعض المناطق خاصه خلال عمليات التوتر
الشديد واضافه هذه القوات الاسرائيليه
الجديده وذلك لمواجهه مايصفونه بالعمليات
والهجمات الارهابيه ضد مواطنين اسرائيليين
في بلده كفر قاسم وهي مسقط راس منفذ هجومي
يومي امس في تل ابيب يوسف ابو جابر في كفر
قاسم كان هناك اقتحام لقوات من الشرطه
والامن الايطالي الى منزله في البلده
وايضا كان هناك مصادره لبعض المواد
والاوراق الخاصه بهم اضافه الى عمليات
استجواب ميدانيه وايضا اقتياد عدد من
الافراد العائله الى محطه شرطه كفر قاسم
للتحقيق معهم في هذا الهجوم الذين فده
ابنهم في يوم مساء يوم امس كل هذه
التداعيات داخل الخط الاخضر وفي داخل
المناطق الاسرائيليه هي تتسوق وتتزامن مع
مواجهات
وعمليات اقتحام وشهدتها المناطق
الفلسطينيه في ساعات الليله الماضيه وايضا
في فجر هذا اليوم هناك كان عصابه اثنين من
الشبان الفلسطينيين احدهما تزعم قوات
الاحتلال بانه ينتمي الى كتائب الشهيد عز
الدين القسام الجناح المصلح لحركه حماس
والذي اصيب خلال اطلاق النار على مركبته
بعدما ان نفذ هجوما او اطلاق عمليه اطلاق
نار على حاجز دوتان غربيه مدينه جنين
وخلال عودته كان هناك كمين قد نصبه قوه
نصبته قوه من المظليين في احراش الاحراش
القريبه من بلده بورقين غربيه مدينه جنين
واطلقت النار عليه ولكنه تمكن من الفرار
وسط تغطيه من المسلحين اخرين قد اشتبكوا
مع جيش الاحتلال ونقل الى المستشفى بعد
اصابته بالرصاصه في الظهر ووفقا للمصادر
الطبيه الفلسطينيه وخلال هذا الاشتباك كان
هناك ايضا اصابه لشاب اخر في القدم مصطفى
جراحو الطفيفه ايضا كان هناك اقتحام محدود
جدا في مخيم نور الشمس في طولكرم حيث كان
هناك
اقتحام مدخل المخيم ونشر القناصه في محيطه
ولكن بعد وقت قصير انسحبت القوات الايصال
للدول ان تنفذ حملات اعتقال او عمليه
عسكريه داخل هذا المخيم اضافه الى ذلك كان
هناك اعتقال لاربعه فلسطينيين ثلاثه منهم
من بلده الرام بعد اقتحامها باليات عسكريه
في الليله الماضيه وايضا كان هناك اعتقال
لشاب من قريه بيت حجار جنوبي بيت لحم
عندما كان يحاول العبور عند حجز الحمراء
في الاغوار الشماليه هناك ايضا كان اقتحام
لعدد من الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه في
قريه تياسير في اطار العمليات البحث
والتمشيط التي تقوم بها قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه بعقبه الهجوم الذي نفذ يوم
امس الجمعه في قربه حاجز الحمراء والذي
ادى ذلك الى مقتل الاثنتين من المستوطنين
المستوطنين وايضا اصابه ثالثه لسيده التي
قالت المصادر الطبيه الاسرائيليه هذا
الصباح بان حالتها ما زالت حرجه جدا في
المستشفى اشكرك سمير ابو جزيره من رام
الله